okay we've got to talk about a problem
that we're experiencing at the David
Pakman show we have had over the years
we've had our share of struggles on the
show when it comes to finances YouTube D
monetization as well as the Amazon
revenue fiasco a couple years ago and
all sorts of different stuff but one
area where we have been killing it over
the last six months is audience growth
we've had nice steady growth for ten
years on the show but the last six
months have just been a period of
massive massive growth and I told you
that in January we had almost 500 new
paid members in February were already
off to a great start with a couple of
hundred new members already the YouTube
channel is growing the subreddit is
growing Facebook Twitter it's all going
very very well in terms of audience but
the downside of this is that we seem to
have gone over sort of some threshold
where there has been a monstrous influx
of nonsense in terms of trolls bots and
chills that a lot of our viewers and
listeners are getting annoyed by and
that's exactly the point of it that's
the point of this trolling and I want to
ask you in the audience today what do
you want us to do about it if anything
and I'll present some options in a
second um how how do you want us to
handle this problem on Twitter we are
being overrun by spammy accounts with
zero followers who only reply to me and
to the show account they exist only to
show up in the replies to stuff that we
post personally I mute them as quickly
as I can but they want to wreak havoc
they want to sow discord that's the
strategy they want to divide our
audience as much as possible and get in
the way of sensible discussion on
YouTube we now have that the numbers are
just stunning
we now have at any given time more than
100,000 comments automatically stuck in
the spam filter we're putting this up on
the screen for people to look at
historically there were between 10 and
20,000 comments at any given time in the
YouTube spam filter we now have as of
when I took the screenshot
111,000 56 comments in the spam filter
this is YouTube's automated spam filter
okay it's not great like tons tons of
non spam will be accidentally flagged
tons of actual spam will get through and
just be posted but historically there's
only about 10 to 20% of this number of
comments stuck in the spam filter a lot
of comments with triple parentheses
around my name right that anti-semitic
thing
often times picking fights with in the
left comments like I hate Trump as much
as the next guy but type of stuff and
then you also have the straight-up bot
comments like we will see 200 comments
come in that are identical from the same
user on 200 different videos in a 5
minute period even the most tech-savvy
individual is not doing that right these
are automated posting systems lately
people have been seizing on issues where
some of my audience disagrees with me to
foment this division and of course there
are plenty of good faith people I want
to be really clear I'm not saying
everybody who disagrees with me about
Venezuela is a bot or a troll I'm not
saying everyone who disagrees with me
about Israel is a bot or a troll but
what I am pointing out is that there are
a lot of accounts on Twitter YouTube and
in particular on reddit that are being
created simply to make one post for
example on our subreddit and over the
weekend I was looking at some of these
and it is really really bad
on Facebook it's brutal what's going on
there people commenting on our page and
tagging us in all sorts of trolling and
nonsense posts so what I am asking for
your advice on here today is what do you
want us to do about this because one
approach and historically the approach
has been we do nothing right on YouTube
we don't ban block or delete comments if
community members flag comments YouTube
might remove them but we don't get
involved because with thousands of
comments a day it's really difficult to
do that the problem is that they win if
we do that pat in that they make it
impossible
for people who want to talk in good
faith about the content of the show to
have conversations and I get emails
every day from people saying David I'm
off your subreddit because it's just
troll central it's just people who are
making it impossible to actually have
conversation so then the opposite
approach would be we now have to get
involved get way more moderators and
start picking what is over the line
beyond just personal attacks which has
historically been been sort of the rule
and we start removing content but then
they also win with that tat because then
we are censoring so I genuinely don't
know what to do about this problem yeah
and I'm going to do my part and start
deleting some of my 6000 accounts on
various social media platforms that are
programmed to leave pro pat propaganda
but I can't be the only one here other
people have to chip in too yeah Pat sock
puppet accounts are going to be removed
by tomorrow morning don't worry about
that so listen this is a big problem and
they sort of win either way because they
either win by making some of these
platforms unusable and really
unpalatable to our core audience or they
win by forcing us to have to make
decisions about what is and isn't going
to be allowed and then it becomes all
about a censoring and doing that type of
thing so I don't know what to do I want
to hear from you about how we should
handle this